I'll build the competition with skiers
at the recently League major it seemed
like there was no clear-cut graffiti
moment and this got us thinking about
some of the most iconic plays that we
could remember from majors past so in no
particular order here's what we think
are some of the most iconic moments in
cs:go major history simple falling on
the site from 2016 ESL one cologne
symbols falling off was not only a
display of insane individual skill but
one that solidified this Ukrainian
prodigy as one of the best players in
the world down 49 in the first half of
cash fnatic went for a force by with
half the team on tech nines and although
the rounds started off poorly for the
Swede they eventually narrowed it down
to a 2v1 situation and headed towards
the B bomb site in what was an
incredible split-second decision simple
decided to jump down from heaven where
he knows he'll Dennis and then noscope
Crim's
and make this play happen simple I don't
know - he comes in he has he has one
fight on his mouth that he had one
button don't blame zoom Team Liquid
would pull off the upset over fnatic
making it all the way to the grand
finals before falling short of sk-gaming
who would win their second straight
major title he goes in human reaction
Rico charge of him Oh God
in human reaction from 2014 ESL one
cologne he goes insane 180 headshot is
still considered one of the most
ridiculous shots of all time in the
opening pistol round of the second map
of their quarterfinal match against ni p
he co was left in an unwinnable one d5
situation after he got a quick kill on
the man on cat the North American ran
past mid doors to the waiting crosshairs
of get right get right would get the
first shot off but he go reacted
instantly
landing one of the noneya shots you will
ever see in your entire life Darren's is
going to be waiting he coach Austin
doesn't take 100 in human reaction
unfortunately Rico and cloud 9 they
would fall just short of ni P 14 to 16
on dust2 than 14 to 16 on cobblestone to
bow out of the tournament at
quarterfinalist
the Cali shot from 2014 ESL one cologne
this shot is still iconic that the acts
of jump headshotting someone on Gus 2
has now become McCallie shine on the
last round of dust to virtus Pro Tasha
and LDL C's Cali were locked in a 1v1
the bomb plant had just gone down and
coming from CT spawn with only 8 HP Kali
landed this ridiculous jumping USP
headshot so that's fine
thanks to the shot ldlc would go on to
beat virtus Pro on dust2
and advance to the semi-final although
this shot is still one of the most
iconic moments in csgo history cali
received a back band and later admitted
himself to having tried a cheaper we
fanatics boost Meister well he's here
he's and now this great headshot they
have no idea miss looking confused and
dazed and it's going to be a because of
it kidding me
fixity receivers from 2014 Dreamhack
winter this boost was at the time the
center of controversy requiring three
people to pull off the booth put
olofmeister in perfect position to see
into pool be long short a and even t
song needless to say this advantage was
immense as olofmeister was able to take
down two players with the scout in the
second round of the half fnatic
continued to use this boost for the rest
of the half and it would take almost the
entire match before ldl-c figured out
where they were getting killed from
there trying to figure out the angle
once again here they try and see if they
could essentially get a cleaner shot
look at this now happy getting boosted
up but it gets spotted all hyper sees it
coming they have accounted for this
fnatic they're one step ahead thanks to
the boost fnatic would win the match but
Dreamhack officials would end up ruling
the boost as illegal and the rematch
would be scheduled but fnatic would
forfeit that match moving past fnatic in
the quarter-final ldl-c would go on to
win the entire tournament calderas
jumping off from the trend he's gonna
hit the ground there's hoho oh don't be
double cone
what is going on right now slowly redo
this coldest April stay with your place
from 2016 MLG Columbus cold airs jumping
off play is one that will definitely go
down in history up 15 to 9 against
luminosity on Mirage Team Liquid made
their way down be apt towards caldera
late into the round with all the world
watching the Brazilian superstar landed
one of the luckiest and yet significant
shot in the history of PS go is a trend
he's gonna hit the ground there's hold
on how do you do this coldest April
equinox T with your place of thinkable
scenes there on the P apartment this
place parked an insane streak of round
wins and in the final six rounds of
regulation LG would only give up a total
of four kills they would go on not only
to win this match but the whole
tournament to take home their first
major championship olofmeister is
burning the fuel over the dispute is
coming in and he's no going has a plane
coming from 2014 ESL one cologne all off
my search burning defuse just might be
the faulty of play on this list after a
roaring comeback in the second half of
overpass fnatic had just even out the
score line 14 to 14 going into the 29th
round team dignitas made a relatively
quick push onto the B bomb site and the
bomb plant would go down early into the
round fnatic reacted quickly on the
retake and as olofmeister jumped on
defuse a molotov was thrown down at
almost the exact same time against all
odds the Swede decided to hold the
defeat and who managed to finish it
before the last tick of damage would
kill them off
the tank really hauls hold on through
around the world over the diffusion the
diffusion tell me nothing no guess it
has a place coming and look at the
little jumps evaporated
banana closed author match against team
dig in the round following this
incredible defuse and they would advance
the grand final of this legendary
tournament fanatics quadruple autonomous
all awps minute they're ready to shoot
some jumpers across the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and not in this
lifetime
he is destroyed from 2015 ESL one
cologne this isn't one of the greatest
plays in the history of the games but
it's definitely one of the most
memorable in the grand final of 2015 ESL
one cologne stands witnessed an
incredible comeback from fnatic on dust2
against team envyus on the final round
of overtime with plenty of cash to spare
fnatic bought four off and decided to
make use of them all setting up a
four-man shooting gallery down mid MBS
his apex was the only challenger to the
shooting squad and he was blown away to
stay the lead and look at the gunfight
Oh AWP cinematic they're ready to shoot
on the docks as they cross the middle
it's gonna be a challenge
not in this large kinetic would go on to
play not only dust you but cobblestone
to secure their third major championship
Nexus Bede life the sex is walking
around
from 2014
EMS Katowice this play is the perfect
display of extreme patience against ni P
in the grand final of this legendary
tournament virtus closes snacks was
lurking towards tea apps and the timing
of the clerk could not be better an
unsuspecting ni p member made his way
upstairs from underpass with his back
completely exposed snacks the Polish
superstar that gave new meaning to the
term trigger discipline that he held off
until the perfect moment to get all
three toes
but then it's walking around he waited
he waited he waited and then he finished
off the job just got to wonder when was
he going to pull the trigger
British Pro would end up taking home
both Mirage and Inferno enroute with
their first major championship and
that's the list let us know in the
comments below if you thought there was
any play we missed and don't forget to
press that like button and subscribe for
more csgo content